[Musik]
und jetzt das heute-journal
panik am flughafen kabul bilder die wohl
in die geschichte eingehen werden so
ging es zum nachdem die mächtige nato
von den taliban überrumpelt wurde
guten abend zum heute-journal der hamid
karzai flughafen der sich ja nicht mehr
lange so heißen wird ist im moment der
einzige weg raus das wissen die menschen
von denen sich manche in ihrer
verzweiflung sogar an abhebende
maschinen hätten sie fürchten zu recht
dass es nicht mehr viele chancen geben
wird überhaupt noch in ein flugzeug zu
kommen das chaos auf dem rollfeld führte
dazu dass die amerikaner den flugverkehr
bis auf weiteres aussetzen mussten auch
deutsche transportmaschinen können
derzeit nicht landen die bundesregierung
hat zwar die wohl größte
evakuierungsaktion in der geschichte der
bundeswehr angekündigt aber niemand kann
im moment sagen wie viele menschen
tatsächlich noch aus afghanistan
gerettet werden können
die neue normalität in karben schwer
bewaffnete taliban patroullieren in der
stadt kontrollieren die straßen mit
resignation nimmt anteil der menschen
diese jüngste dramatische wende in ihrer
geschichte hin
seit jetzt 40 jahren leben wir im krieg
nichts als kampf und elend ich hoffe
jetzt kommt endlich frieden und das
töten hat ein ende
daran glauben diese afghanen nicht vor
dem flughafen schüsse es herrscht chaos
heute verzweifelte menschen familien mit
kindern die irgendwie weg wollen solange
es noch geht mittendrin schwer
bewaffnete taliban kämpfer die immer
wieder das feuer eröffnet
auf dem flughafengelände herrscht
entsetzen menschen versuchen mit aller
kraft an bord einer maschine zu gelangen
obwohl der linienflugverkehr eingestellt
wurde auch militärflugzeuge konnten
vorübergehend nicht mehr landen weil
sich tausende menschen auf die rollbahn
drängten verzweifelt hängten sie sich an
bereits staaten der amerikanische
militärmaschinen
vergeblich bemühten sich us soldaten dem
militärischen teil des flughafens zu
sichern bei schusswechseln wurden nach
us-angaben zwei bewaffnete getötet im
präsidentenpalast in kabul ließen sich
unterdessen die neuen machthaber filmen
ihre führer danken gott für den sieg
gratulierten ihren kämpfern und
versuchten zugleich die bevölkerung zu
beruhigen
wir werden der afghanischen nation
langen und wir werden für sicherheit und
ein besseres leben sorgen
soweit das versprechen viele afghanen
und afghaninnen erinnern sich aber noch
mit schrecken an die dunklen jahre der
gewaltherrschaft der taliban vor mehr
als 20 jahren der hochschullehrer rahimi
der sich inzwischen in istanbul aufhält
hofft dass sich die gemäßigten kräfte
bei den taliban durchsetzen
die panik vor allem in kabul muss
beendet werden das geht nur durch neues
vertrauen durch taten nicht durch worte
die taliban sagen viel aber die leute
glauben ihnen nicht
in new york beriet der sicherheitsrat
der vereinten nationen und über die lage
generalsekretär gute risch appellierte
an die taliban die menschenrechte aller
bürger insbesondere von frauen und
mädchen zu respektieren die kommenden
tage seien entscheidend
20 jahre bei der westen einschließlich
bundeswehr in afghanistan
monate lang wusste man wann die letzten
truppen abziehen sollen und dann ein
solches chaos eine solch demütigende
form der flucht bei der auch
botschaftspersonal um leib und leben
fürchten muss hinzu kommt die scham
darüber dass ich jetzt so viele afghanen
bitterlich im stich gelassen fühlen man
habe die lage falsch eingeschätzt hieß
es heute in berlin das wirft viele
fragen auf wie konnte es zu dieser
fehleinschätzung kommen gab es noch
nicht mal mehr spezialkräfte und
nachrichtendienste auf afghanischem
boden wurden warnungen der deutschen
botschaft in kabul überhört fragen die
ich gerne den bundesaußenminister oder
der bundesverteidigungsministerium
gestellt hätte leider haben uns beide
abgesagt dafür sprechen wir gleich mit
einem bundeswehrsoldaten der schon seit
langem auf eigene initiative versucht
afghanische ortskräfte der bundeswehr
zurück doch zuvor der bericht aus berlin
von andreas cüppers
am fliegerhorst wunstorf am beginn eines
denkwürdigen tages fängt die kamera sie
ein die fallschirmjäger der division
schnelle kräfte die militärpolizisten
und sanitäter die zu einem der
dramatischsten der unkalkulierbar ssten
einsätze in der geschichte der
bundeswehr aufbrechen drei
transportflugzeuge a400m starten ins
ungewisse auftrag alle deutschen retten
und so viele ihrer helfer wie möglich
unser hauptziel ist gerade denen die uns
sehr direkt geholfen haben eine
perspektive zu bieten ob wir die
umsetzen können dass es hängt von den
gegebenheiten jetzt in kabul ab das
haben wir leider nicht mehr voll in der
hand aber wir werden auch danach in
gesprächen mit den taliban und über alle
unsere kanäle versuchen möglichst vielen
menschen zu helfen die deutschen
evakuierungs flieger landen am frühen
abend zunächst im aserbaidschanischen
baku tanten dort auf und schalten die
transponder ab dann versucht der erste
in kabul zu landen aber noch immer
herrscht chaos auf der landebahn der
airbus tritt ab und wartet nun im
usbekischen taschkent dass die
bundesregierung zu spät evakuiert dass
sie die taliban unterschätzt und die
afghanische armee überschätzt hat räumen
außenminister und kanzlerin am abend
erstmals ein es gibt auch nichts zu
beschönigen wir alle die bundesregierung
die nachrichtendienste die
internationale gemeinschaft wir haben
die lage falsch eingeschätzt wir haben
alle und dann übernehme ich auch die
verantwortung die entwicklung falsch
eingeschätzt ich schließe mich da dem
bundesaußenminister an dass zum beispiel
am 9 juni als maß in der fragestunde des
bundestags zu mehr tempo gedrängt wurde
ich will mal sagen all diese fragen
haben ja die grundlage dass in wenigen
wochen die taliban in afghanistan
das zepter in der hand haben das ist
nicht die grundlage meiner annahme der
größte fehler aber dass man sich auf die
eventualität dass das passieren könnte
nicht eingestellt hat wir haben jetzt
eine situation wo alles ganz
kompliziertes man jetzt dass es bei
fachleuten die nebel des krieges der
sich über alles legt weil so viel
gleichzeitig passiert das hätte man als
eventualität ein planken zum
hauptschuldigen erklärt die union heute
heiko maas als im cdu-vorstand essens
oberbürgermeister kufen vom
schlechtesten außenminister den
deutschland je hatte spricht stellt
cdu-chef laschet lakonisch fest kein
widerspruch die opposition wirft beiden
regierungsparteien vor noch ende juni
ein aufnahmeprogramm für ortskräfte
abgelehnt zu haben
diese unterlassene hilfe der
bundesregierung die wird menschen das
leben kosten und es ist so furchtbar
dass es vermutlich vor einige zu spät
ist und dass wir einige nicht mehr
evakuieren können seit einer stunde
kreis das zweite am morgen gestartete
flugzeug über kabul und wieder heißt es
landung derzeit nicht möglich die
deutsche außenpolitik muss jetzt hoffen
auf glück
akkus grotjahn hauptmann der bundeswehr
ist uns zugeschaltet er hat das
patenschafts netzwerk für afghanische
ortskräfte gegründet kümmert sich also
schon seit jahren um afghanische
ortskräfte der bundeswehr und war dort
selbst in kundus stationiert guten abend
herr
schick und mit wie vielen leuten orts
kräften und familien sind sie im moment
noch in kontakt
jetzt mit nur noch wenigen wir haben
heute vormittag noch zu circa 1300
ortskräfte und ihren angehörigen kontakt
gehabt im raum kabul danach mussten wir
leider die safe hause auflösen denn sie
wurden langsam zu todesfallen die
taliban gegen von tür zu tür und suchen
nach unseren ort kräften daraufhin haben
wir gesagt sie sollen die orte die safe
hause verlassen und sich in der
bevölkerung untertauchen diese safe
hauses also weil sie geheim gehaltene
häuser in denen sich ortskräfte familien
versteckten die haben auch sie auf
eigene initiative oder mit
nichtregierungsorganisationen
gesuchte hat jetzt auch der deutsche
staat nicht groß bei geholfen sehe ich
das richtig
leider nein wir hätten sonst schon
früher auch ausfliegen können wir hätten
auch früher viel mehr menschen nach
kabul bringen können leider hat man uns
da nicht unterstützt als wir dann das
geld für zum beispiel charter maschinen
hatten war es zu spät da flog keiner
mehr nach kabul ein wie bewerten sie
denn sie sind ja auch soldaten moment
die situation an am flughafen glauben
sie dass da noch sehr viele maschinen
starten und landen werden was was hören
sie von leuten aus kabul vor ort
mein eindruck ist kein guter gewesen
deshalb habe ich mich heute vormittag
dazu entschlossen es
gibt auch einen wohl auch einen äußeren
ring von taliban um den flughafen
drumherum das selbst wenn flieger landen
könnten kommen da ortskräfte von außen
wahrscheinlich nicht mehr zu den
maschinen das muss man jetzt alles sehen
was ich wie sich die nächsten stunden
entwickeln zurzeit landen da ja auch
keiner im moment landet hat niemand das
heißt sie glauben dass es auch sehr
schwierig wird für tausende menschen die
jetzt angeblich eigentlich rausgeholt
werden sondern überhaupt zum flughafen
zu kommen weil das schon gar nicht mehr
möglich ist
ich halte das für nicht realistisch das
ist auch eine harte aussage wir haben
wir haben ihre freunde dann sind ja auch
dann zum teil haben sie kennen ja auch
einige persönlich wie haben sie reagiert
als sie sagten deutschen ist aus diesem
safe house raus ihm ist jetzt dort weg
sie waren genauso schockiert wie wir
dass wir an diesem punkt kommen wo wir
keine antworten mehr haben und den
leuten sagen viel glück das haben wir
immer befürchtet wir haben es angemahnt
dass es passieren könnte wir haben
lösungen aufgezeigt die keiner hören
wollte wir haben probleme aufgezeigt die
alle immer super trotzdem toll laufen
sollten angeblich und nun lassen wir 80
prozent unserer ortskräfte und ihre
familien in die hände der taliban find
das ist das ergebnis sie meinen mit
problemen die es gab und wo angeblich
dinge toll laufen diese offenbar sehr
umständliche visaverfahren die bis vor
kurzem noch betrieben wurden
da sind sie besser informiert als ich
nach meinem kenntnisstand hat nicht ein
einziges visaverfahren seit juni
angefangen wenn da visaverfahren
gelaufen wären dann wären hätten wir uns
alle gefreut stattdessen haben
ortskräfte monate lang mindestens wochen
mindestens acht bis zehn wochen haben
sie sich in kabul aufgehalten weil sie
die hoffnung hatten dass sie dort einen
weg in die freiheit finden können das
perfide ist halt auch dass dieser visa
oder dieser auf ortskräfte verfahren
kann nur in afghanistan
gestartet werden wenn man ins
nachbarland flieht dann ist man nicht
mehr antragsberechtigt das hat die
ortskräfte in kabul und in afghanistan
gehalten sie mussten zu einem büro was
nie funktioniert hat was nie
eingerichtet war von der aon und da
haben sie bis zum schluss darauf
gewartet und jetzt sitzen sie in einer
todesfalle und das ist ja das ist das
ergebnis dieser politischen entscheidung
man merkt die bitter sie darüber sind
sie haben ja auch als soldat in kunduz
gestanden haben dort auch ihr leben
riskiert wie empfinden sie und leben
finden befreundete soldaten ja dass wenn
man sie jetzt diese bilder sieht wie die
taliban durch den durch den palast
zwischen präsidentenpalast spazieren
wie sie das gesamtpolitische bild das
ist mir zur zeit
ich bin fokussiert auf die hilfe der
ortskräfte dass das zurzeit
400 500 nachrichten die uns erreichen
denen wir nicht mehr helfen werden
können offenbar das ist das was uns zur
zeit hier belastet ob und wie
afghanistan im gesamtkontext zu bewerten
ist dass er zurzeit andere machen ich
kümmere mich um die ortskräfte mit
unseren helfern und da so schockierend
genug brot ja nicht danken für das
gespräch und ich hoffe dass sie dass sie
noch helfen können
wir hoffen auch
das gespräch haben wir kurz vor der
sendung geführt dass die taliban das
land nach anfänglichen gefechten dann
fast widerstandslos übernehmen konnten
dafür wird es wohl verschiedene gründe
geben eines scheint jedenfalls
rückblickend klar sie haben ihren
durchmarsch sehr gut vorbereitet nicht
nur militärstrategie wussten offenbar
auch wie sie schon im vorfeld
schlüsselfiguren auf ihre seite ziehen
provinzpolitiker oder generäle der
afghanischen armee
während der westen sich noch staunend
die augen reibt schaffen die taliban nun
fakten mit einem zwar mittelalterliche
weltbild aber durchaus modernen methoden
whatsapp etwa nutzen sie auch
katrin eigendorf berichtet über die
stadt ghasni liegt rund 150 kilometer
südwestlich von kabul
ein afghanischer kameramann konnte dort
heute für uns filmen die flagge der
taliban wird überall in der
provinzmetropole ghasemi nur 150
kilometer von kabul entfernt hier haben
die islamisten die macht bereits vor
vier tagen übernommen taliban regeln den
verkehr haben rund um die stadt
checkpoints eingerichtet alle
staatlichen einrichtungen haben sie mit
ihren leuten besetzt gerichte schulen
krankenhäuser viele der kämpfer stammen
aus der stadt sie sind gut ausgerüstet
us-militär fahrzeuge waffen alles hat
ihnen der gouverneur überlassen kampflos
auch die medien haben sie übernommen
die fernseh und radiosender senden und
arbeiten jetzt nach scharia gesetz
mindestens 15 mitarbeiter der alten
belegschaft arbeiten jetzt für uns die
anderen haben wir kontaktiert
gar nie so sagen die taliban ist jetzt
teil des islamischen emirats afghanistan
eine terrorgruppe regiert bilder die bei
vielen afghanen erinnerungen wecken an
die 90er jahre
kritisch äußert sich niemand vor der
kamera aber es gibt auch menschen die
zufrieden sind vor allem damit dass
jetzt ordnung herrsche seitdem ist zum
glück das islamische emirat gibt sind
die straßen die vorher blockiert waren
wieder offen die leute sind glücklich
wie schnell sie nicht nur die stadt
einnehmen konnten sondern auch alle
staatlichen stellen zeigt sie kämpfen
brutal sind aber auch gut organisiert
moderner als die taliban die vor 20
jahren in afghanistan herrschten und sie
wissen um die macht der medien sie haben
ihre eigenen radiosender verbreiten ihre
nachrichten machen videoclips für ihre
social media kanäle in afghanistan gilt
jetzt die scharia die menschen müssen
sich den neuen gesetzen fügen das sind
ihre wichtigsten botschaften frauen
dürfen nicht mehr ohne männliche
begleitung auf die straße verschleierung
ist pflicht inzwischen sind fast nur
noch männer in den straßen der stadt zu
sehen
die wenigen errungenschaften der
vergangenen 20 jahre in nicht einmal
einer woche ausgelöst wie in gasen wird
es künftig in ganz afghanistan aussehen
eine islamistische diktatur in der
frauen- und menschenrechte und freiheit
keine geltung mehr haben
später im heute-journal update ist der
frühere bundeswehr general hans lothar
domröse zu gast aber stabschef der isaf-
mission in kabul eine maria schuck
spricht dann mit ihm unter anderem über
die militärische lage und weshalb man
die taliban so unterschätzt hat
jetzt kommen wir gleich zu anderen
nachrichten die heute von den
ereignissen in kabul etwas überschattet
werden zunächst in einer meldung der wir
an anderen tagen unsere sendung
vermutlich begonnen hätten heinz werde
die ständige impfkommission spricht nun
für allgemeine corona impfungen für alle
kinder und jugendlichen ab zwölf jahren
aus das gremium teilte mit nach
sorgfältiger bewertung neuer daten komme
man nun zu der einschätzung dass nach
gegenwärtigem wissensstand die vorteile
der impfung gegenüber dem risiko sehr
seltener impfnebenwirkungen überwiegen
bisher hatte die stiko die impfung in
der altersgruppe nur bei bestimmten
umständen die vorerkrankungen empfohlen
baden württemberg ändert seine krone
regelungen und richtet sie nicht mehr
allein nach incident stufen aus zu
dürfen etwa theater aktuell wieder
komplett öffnen dafür gelten sogenannte
3g regeln in weiten teilen des
öffentlichen lebens also geimpft gelesen
oder getestet muss man dafür seien die
masken pflicht gilt grundsätzlich weiter
und jetzt zu den corona zahlen in
deutschland das robert koch institut
meldet 2126 neuinfektionen binnen 24
stunden
943 mehr als vor einer woche und vier
weitere todesfälle im zusammenhang mit
cupid 19 die sieben tage incident steigt
auf
36,2
in haiti suchen einsatzkräfte weiter
nach opfern des schweren erdbebens vom
samstag die zahl der todesopfer hat sich
nach angaben des haitianischen
zivilschutzes auf fast 1300 erhöht
zahlreiche menschen werden noch vermisst
mit einer stärke von 7,2 hatte das beben
am wochenende tausende häuser zerstört
oder beschädigt in den nächsten stunden
soll ein tiefdruckgebiet auf die schwer
betroffene südküste der insel treffen
rettungsarbeiten könnten dadurch
behindert werden das us-hurrikan-zentrum
warnt vor überschwemmungen und
erdrutschen
zurück nach deutschland ein teil der
energiewende ist der ausbau der
elektromobilität daran wird auch in
deutschland intensiv gearbeitet heute
war ein darmstadt termin zur eröffnung
einer fabrik für batteriesysteme frank
bethmann wie sind die kapazitäten da
inzwischen in deutschland naja sie bauen
sich nun doch erfreulich schnell auf
nachdem es lange so aussah als hätte das
autoland deutschland hier den anschluss
verloren wendet sich das blatt gerade
nicht nur in darmstadt bei akasol fast
überall hierzulande werden nun diese
sogenannten giga factory es gebaut von
den globalen automobilkonzern und
batterieherstellern darunter viele
amerikanische und chinesische
deutschland so die prognose ist jetzt
sogar auf dem besten weg in europa der
wichtigste produktionsstandort von
batteriezellen für elektroautos zu
werden wichtig ist dies gleich aus zwei
gründen
denn beim bau eines elektroautos
entfallen ungefähr 40 prozent der
gesamten wertschöpfung auf jedes bauteil
auf die zelle gleichzeitig ist die
batterie und hier insbesondere die
produktion der batteriezelle für rund 30
bis 60 prozent der
treibhausgasemissionen verantwortlich
während das elektroauto also als
klimafreundlich gilt ist es die
fertigung des akkus keineswegs im
gegenteil
deswegen werde es in den kommenden
jahren darum gehen batterien
klimaneutral zu produzieren hier sind
fachleute die herausforderung aber
gleichzeitig auch eine riesenchance für
den automobilstandort deutschland frank
wittmann vielen dank gerne wegen
steigender corona infektionszahlen in
japan werden auch die paralympischen
spiele in tokio weitgehend ohne publikum
stattfinden wie die verantwortlichen aus
sport und politik mit halten soll es
eine ausnahme nur für einige
schülerinnen und schüler geben während
der paralympics werden mehr als
katholiken während der paralympics
werden mehr als 4000 teilnehmer aus rund
160 ländern um die medaillen wetteifern
mit dem spiele beginnen am 24 august
und wir kommen noch mal kurz zum thema
afghanistan zurück die bundesregierung
wurde heute nicht müde zu betonen alle
hätten die lage falsch eingeschätzt auch
die amerikaner das ist wohl wahr und der
us-regierung wird darüber hinaus nicht
nur vorgehalten dass sie sich zu früh
auf einen abzug festlegte sondern auch
wie schlecht sie ihn am ende
durchgeführt hat und dann hat sich joe
biden vor wenigen minuten erstmals dazu
öffentlich geäußert unser korrespondent
mrt wissen hat das in washington nicht
angehört immer was was hat der präsident
gesagt
ja der präsident hat seine entscheidung
für einen rückzug aus afghanistan noch
einmal sehr ausdrücklich gerechtfertigt
er hat rückgriff genommen auf das was
vor 20 jahren vereinbart wurde nämlich
dass die hauptziele so sagt joe biden
gewesen sein die angreifer vom 11
september
2001 zur rechenschaft zu ziehen und
zweitens sicherzustellen dass nie wieder
solch ein angriff ein terroranschlag aus
einem anderen in diesem fall afghanistan
herausgeführt und vorbereitet werden
kann diese ziele sagte er seien bereits
vor zehn jahren erreicht gewesen und
jetzt kommt hinzu dass zur mission aus
seiner sicht sagt er niemals dazu gehört
habe tatsächlich einen demokratischen
staat zu schaffen also nation building
zu betreiben das stimmt aus meiner sicht
nicht mit dem überein was in den letzten
20 jahren dann doch versucht worden ist
in afghanistan ja sagt jedenfalls das
sei nicht teil der mission deswegen ist
der abzug richtig denn mann stand vor
der entscheidung entweder
abzuziehen so wie es sein vorgänger
donald trump ja beschlossen und auch
verkündet hatte auch mit den taliban
vereinbart hatte eigentlich schon zum
ersten mai diesen jahres oder eben zu
eskalieren also eine massive eskalation
und da hat der präsident den satz
gesprochen der ich glaube auch bei
vielen amerikanern hängenbleiben wird er
sagt amerikaner können und sollten nicht
ihr leben riskieren und ihr leben
verlieren in einem krieg den die
afghanen selber die afghanische armee
nicht bereit ist zu kämpfen also eine
klare rechtfertigung für die
entscheidung er nimmt jetzt in diesen
sekunden bezug darauf dass die planungen
ganz offenbar ja schief gelaufen sind in
den letzten tagen aber eher zu hören wie
ihr wird auch verteidigen dass er sagte
es gab pläne falls die taliban
tatsächlich viel schneller die macht
erobern als man gedacht hatte und das
ist etwas was in den nächsten tagen
amerika versuchen wird noch gut zu
machen indem man den flughafen sichert
um so vielen menschen wie möglich noch
die flucht zu ermöglichen
aber der präsident sagt sehr klar der
auftrag amerikas in bezug auf
afghanistan bezieht sich ausschließlich
darauf auch in zukunft dafür zu sorgen
dass keine terroranschläge von diesem
land mehr ausgehen danke schon einmal
für diese aktuellen informationen aus
washington
dass angela merkel an einem tag wie
heute dann abends trotzdem noch zu einer
film premiere gekommen ist es hat gründe
sie taucht in dem film selbst auf neben
vielen anderen deutschen politikerinnen
und es ist ein politischer film die
unbeugsam so der titel zeichnet ein
sittenbild der bonner republik mit
welchen widerständen die ersten frauen
zu kämpfen hatten in der politik fuß
fassten woran sich die frauen erinnern
was in diesem film erzählen welche
szenen sie erlebt haben was macht ein
streckenweise geradezu fassungslos
manches mal muss man lachen bis es einem
im halse stecken bleibt und auch wenn es
um die bonner republik geht bleiben
reichlich bezüge zur gegenwart unbedingt
ansehen sagt unsere filmkritikerin
sabine schulz
[Musik]
es ist eine zeitreise in eine von
männern dirigierte welt
[Musik]
im orchester wie im parlament
frauen hatten damals in den 50er jahren
andere sorgen da waren sich die männer
einig eine frau hat zwei lebensfragen
was soll ich anziehen und was soll ich
kochen
solange uns männer regieren wird es hier
nicht besser werden eine demokratie kann
nicht nur halb seien zur ganzheit eines
volkes gehirn frauen und männer
der weg ins parlament war voller hürden
die mutigen frauen der ersten stunde der
nachkriegszeit der bonner republik
politikerinnen aller parteien der
regisseur nennt sie die unbeugsamen
fast allen gemeinsam ist dass sie alle
in ihren positionen mitunter die erste
waren also die erste die eine junge
gruppierung vorsatz die erste ministerin
also all diese frauen waren in ihren
bereichen mitunter pionierinnen können
sie das normal dass eine frau ein
solches amt ausüben kann wir haben weder
etwas gegen alte frauen wir haben auch
nichts gegen junge frauen sie schauen
sich zum teil ganz passabel an wir
fordern sie alle auch den alltäglichen
sexismus hier im parlament einzustellen
was muss für frauen im bundestag
aushalten verhöhnt verniedlicht
belästigt ich hatte nie die letzte rede
zu reden und dann gehe ich zurück zum
einen platz wo ich dann winter auf
halbem wege steht stücklen vor mir sagt
schuchardt nimmt seinen daumen geht über
meinen rücken und macht plötzlich in die
csu so also was man darin
ja wir haben gewertet rechts mbh oder
trixi kein lassen so so tolle frauen die
sind so i look wenn die herren caris mal
die haben witz die wissen sich gegen
diese ganzen männer anfeindungen der
damaligen zeit zu behaupten also das
waren für mich großartige entdeckung
eine große freude so was zu sehen im
archiv das ist sie rita süßmuth
nachfolgerin geißlers professoren es
muss geschmeidig wird
der regisseur verzichtet auf jeden
kommentar er überlässt das wort den
frauen mit ihren bahnbrechenden reden
und süffisanten erinnerungen in den 70er
und 80er jahren eine frau als kanzlerin
war unvorstellbar unvorstellbar wenn die
wahl gewesen zwischen der besten frau
von allen in 70ern und einem dummen
august wieder dumme august
ja klar
und heute nach 16 jahren bundeskanzlerin
im bundestag jedoch ist der frauenanteil
wieder rückläufig beträgt nur noch 31
prozent sind wir auf dem weg zur rolle
rückwärts und so hat die botschaft
dieses sehenswerten films nichts an
aktualität verloren
[Musik]
das belegt auch das fernsehen gleich
nach dem wetter geht es mit einem
agententhriller weiter und um 23 55
meldet sich anna maria schuck mit dem
roger schneider update auf wiedersehen
ist morgens wieder sehen
[Musik]
guten abend für viele war das ja noch
mal ein sehr sommerliches wochenende das
ändert sich jetzt und das liegt an
diesem tief dass in den nächsten tagen
über das baltikum weiter in richtung
finnland sieht aber schon zum nächsten
wochenende könnte das nächste tief vom
atlantik aus südwesteuropa wieder
sommerliche wärme zu uns bringen aber
der reihe nach erst mal bekommen wir es
mit diesem tief luciano zu tun dass über
die ostsee weiter nach nordosten zieht
das bringt regen am alpenrand aber
morgen nachmittag dann auch wieder von
belgien und den niederlanden ja es ist
ein sturmtief was da heran brauchst also
bedeutet es gibt stürmische böen 70 80
kilometer pro stunde an den küsten aber
auch in den nördlichen mittelgebirgen
diesen kräftigen wind den merken wir
schon in der nacht da ziehen etliche
schauer und gewitter über
norddeutschland oscars und auch am
alpenrand regnet es länger und das bei
temperaturen von 14 grad auf den
ostfriesischen inseln und bis 7 grad in
der eifel morgen liegen die
höchsttemperaturen in den mittelgebirgen
so um die 15 grad sonst sind es 17 bis
18 am oberrhein sogar 21 grad und auch
morgen über tag ziehen bei diesen recht
kräftigen westwind etliche schauer und
gewitter über norddeutschland hinweg und
nachmittags tauchen dann die neuen
regenwolken hier von den niederlanden
und von belgien hier auf sonst wird das
ein recht freundlicher tag sonne und
wolken wechseln sich ab und auch wenn es
wechselhaft weiter geht so wird es doch
von tag zu tag ein kleines bisschen
milder am freitag liegen die höchstwerte
bei 19 bis 25 grad gute nacht